yeah welcome to this video five minute
game yeah let's try this kemar variation
again when i'm trying to remember what
John Watson recommended in this video
series so f6 is my counter play hmm yeah
still have six spoon don't know maybe
did I did I commit some what makes a
mistake already here hmm f6 if it takes
yeah he can take you six out the ship
Bishop takes roughly 6 mm but d4 is
hanging
hmm yeah I don't want to be too passive
here and maybe I can jump okay I wasn't
really wasn't even sure how to take it
on f6 this doesn't look down to
threatening in comparison should I i
need to i want to clarify the situation
with this Bishop it's really annoying so
night should I go 95 yelled as this kick
before coming
many hard to play without that I Bishop
be one I had a little bit more respect
simply because um it looked the Queen's
to look like dangerous are a dangerous
idea Queenie 8 is to prevent queen age 5
you're okay i can take with the bishop
even
yeah probably i should do that no just
just go back doesn't matter and this
isn't too bad but maybe rupee 3h three
something like that this could be it
could be a problem okay I'm but unlucky
three year or I can also play 9 to e
four so this this is an interesting idea
anyway giving up on Dance c5 Bishop c6
activating
no it's not a bad idea maybe something
to to go for with the correct timing
look here idea form okay let's do that
it is interesting and then Bishop c6
especially with the bishop a bit silly
on d to the some gains a bit in strength
so just be 60 or here yeah this is good
taking the Queen and attending a form if
he doesn't protect the bishop
so now but I have this month now yeah
this is this is getting getting tricky
very tricky for white light squares now
so hmm yeah I didn't really I can just
take it I was really shocked that this
mice was risen was calling because I
thought before while we must pop he must
play Queenie too and then then he did
play it I guess I guess this is a pretty
pretty decent one second yeah will you
computer actually gives black and
baguettes here so I judge deserve this
correctly and now queen g six wins
already yeah yeah it is very very
dangerous i mean queen g to mate a for
group d three this activates the bishop
enormously this is the sequence the
computer wrong button sorry what is the
computer saying hi it doesn't want to
take it once to play Bishop e3 now now
it's probably better this this really
activates the light squared Bishop
enormously 92 is that the computer wants
to go limiting a black tour to a slight
edge
and it's also hanging yeah it was a
pretty pretty decent points egg at least
leading to let's say about equal chances
and the way you play t quickly fell
apart here I'm after Queenie too there's
at least this this possible winning
material Wow alright thanks for watching